all right it's uh a little couple of
minutes after one I will call them uh
meeting up the house uh uh Judiciary
Committee to order and I'm uh first
going to ask representative briefs and
if he lead us from the pledge pledge of
allegiance
and to the Republic for which it stands
for all
thank you
so what I wanted to uh note just for for
everybody's uh
information first of all I did pass
around and I apologize for not doing
this earlier I did pass around the the
copies of the uh of the listing of
everyone's email and phone numbers
um so that everyone everyone should have
that
um the other thing I want to let
everyone know is that there is there
will be a notice going out
in fact
um of a revised executive sessions for
next week on we're going to have
executive sessions Wednesday and
Thursday of next week but on Wednesday
we will start at 11 o'clock not at nine
o'clock and then on Thursday we will
start it at nine uh and and my for for
the Republican members of the of the
committee my plan is to have uh a caucus
uh at nine o'clock on Wednesday here in
this room do we so we can talk about
what what's gonna what we're gonna do
um at once once we start at 11. uh so
what I would like to do if I could just
take a minute because
um I know that a number of people are
new on the committee and and candidly
I'm new as chair of the committee and so
I just want to kind of go over things I
think I've got this correct but if uh if
I don't I will ask uh representative
Smith or representative Wallace to
correct
so I I should say
um at the beginning that representative
Smith and I have spoken this morning
um to basically try to you know see
where we're both where both sides so to
speak are and I think you'll uh you will
be happy to see that uh we are
um in in agreement on a great many of
what we're about to what we're going to
discuss
um
the um but just just to kind of go
through this
um where it appears to me
um
um that there is disagreement I will
call on a republican for the motion
favoring my view on the bill I believe
that's my priority as a chair uh we will
have a full debate on the bill don't get
me wrong everybody will have a full
opportunity to have a debate on the bill
um if there is a motion if if there is a
motion uh on a bill of ought to pass and
there's amendments we will deal with the
Amendments first uh and then get to the
main bill
it's my understanding and again I ask my
colleagues to correct me if I'm wrong
that
um unless there's an objection
amendments can be voted on by either a
show of hands or a Voice vote whereas
but once we get once we then get to the
main motion either the amendment passes
or it fails but then we get to the main
bill that has to be a roll call vote um
in all cases
as I said my plan is to allow a full
debate
um on on all the bills if whether we you
know if we have an agreement or not
um
uh but I will I I will not allow a
filibuster so that once everybody has
had an opportunity to have to fully
speak and have their say I will then
call for uh for a vote uh if the first
motion uh succeeds then that's sort of
the end of the matter and that will be
the recommendation uh of the committee
if the motion fails there can then be
another motion for example if there's a
motion of itl and that fails there can
then be a motion of ought to pass or
some other motion if both uh if for
example both emotion uh uh to itl fails
and then a motion of ought to pass fails
then the bill will go to the floor
without recommendation and both sides
May file a report explaining their
explaining their position is that uh
there can be other motions such as
retain or whatever yes for sure
um
the um consent calendar uh uh requires
as I understand it uh either unanimous
or near unanimous agreement on a on a
bill for it to be put on the consent
calendar and it cannot have a fiscal
impact unless it's a bill with a fiscal
impact that we are voting itl because
then there isn't any fiscal impact
uh
reports uh the the uh
the history on the practice of the house
has been that um if uh if you are the
one that moves a uh emotion
um and that that then and uh you then
you write the report on the motion if
you're the one that's that seconds it
then you if there's a debate on the
floor you will do the the Parliamentary
inquiry concerning it but that doesn't
you know that's just the practice
obviously if if uh if on my side of the
aisle so to speak uh people you know I
people want to have a discussion about
that or want to have somebody else do it
we can have a discussion about that and
the same would be true
um with representative Smith on the on
the other side of the aisle
um
to just take a couple of seconds so
people don't get
um sort of overly concerned about
reports especially if you haven't done
it before
these are not these reports are not term
papers it's two or three sentences but
basically explaining what the bill would
would propose to do and why you either
if your Society supports it or doesn't
support it why you support the
recommendation that that that has been
made or if you're in the minority why
you support another recommendation and
then the the uh there has to be in the
report it has to stay what the vote was
of the committee
um uh on the when the bill came to the
floor
um
the uh so and the other thing I would
say is um if you have ques if you're
assigned to write a report and you have
questions and you're you know you're in
you're on the majority party don't
hesitate to contact me and talk to me
about it and if you have if you're on
the in the other party you should call
Representative Smith and speak to her
about it
um we but we will both be reviewing the
reports that are filed and then they
eventually go to the speaker and he
reviews them also
um so I I guess I would say
um
uh you know that
my suggestion would be you want to uh
you want to explain what the bill says
and and your your sort of party or your
your sides so to speak view on the bill
um
without my suggestion would be on books
to both sides that it be in a kind of
respectful and non-sort of
confrontational manner
yes representative Tripp
have we finished the report who do we
submit it to submit it to uh you you
submit it to me and and if you're and if
you're if you're in the in the uh the
Democrats would submit it to
representative Smith at least first and
then it would eventually it would come
to me but it should go to her first for
her review
um and and this is uh what I would see
what I'm going to suggest is the bills
we're executing today I'm going to ask
that if we have that the reports from
both sides be in by the close of
business this Friday
um that will allow us to make sure that
it can you know it can get onto the it
can get into the record so that it can
be put on uh it can be put in the
uh the calendar for next week and then
go on the next uh you might want to make
it noon tonight oh noon time for us but
going to the channel
well that's right no I'm sorry it would
be the calendar for the following would
be the count yeah so right for the next
week would be Thursday into business
right right but I guess I'd like to I
mean just so that it gives us it gives
everyone time for us to review it the
speaker to review it and again I so I
would I would request that you have the
reports in by this Friday at the close
of business that you're much more
generous than that
yes uh representative walls thank you
chairman
um it might make sense since most of us
are pretty organized we know the Motions
were going to be make I would suggest
that if you think you might be making a
motion on a particular Bill have the
blurb written written and with you that
way you're off the hook when we're done
we're done makes sense
foreign
supports um is there a form available in
the office or is it an online that we
can obtain the form okay
there used to be a form to do that it
was a blue or a yellow sheet depending
on the majority of minority but it can
be you can just do a an email template
and write your paragraph a couple of
sentences touch on your points
and you can just submit it directly like
that without a form via email
okay Caitlyn does have yes Caitlyn
doesn't yeah and Mr Cherry do you want
us to send the reports to you directly
or to the to the secretary
um uh actually I would I would copy both
of us on it and again for the for the
Democrats you should send your report to
representative Smith alone first so that
she gets to review it and make you know
she may have suggested changes or
whatever and only after only after she's
done reviewing it should what should it
come to me so with that so it goes you
know each side sort of submits their
reports through the chain of commands so
to speak to to their side and then once
their side is satisfied with it then it
can then it'll it'll go uh go to the
other go to me and then go to the
speaker anybody have any questions on on
any of that
all right um then first I'm going to
turn to uh
hv67fn relative to the right to review
source code of software in criminal
cases and I will recognize
representative Stapleton for a motion
I move Ito on HB 67.
um believing that the
let me just ask is there a second
the second of Alexander seconds
all right yes discussion uh
representative yeah I think it's uh
two fine and too narrow uh of a uh of a
need and not many people uh are capable
of uh looking into source code without
third party assistance and I I just it
doesn't make sense it doesn't seem
practicable for Value uh in in criminal
cases of evidence right other other
people any other comments on this of any
kind
um I I guess I would just say uh very
briefly that
um as was pointed out at the hearing uh
the courts have authority to order the
production of source codes in particular
cases if there's some basis to believe
that there's a problem with Source codes
this bill would sort of make it like
just sort of automatic that Source codes
are available it would as as was stated
at the hearing it would present issues
of uh of uh intellectual property rights
of of people who who own the source code
so to speak third parties so I think it
I think representative stapleton's
motion is very well taken
um uh other people anyone else have any
comments on
are we ready for a vote
all right uh then I would uh
ask for a roll call vote on this and ask
the clerk if she would please call the
roll
on the motion of itl for house bill
67-ffn
rep Wallace
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes
reps testerman
rep Stapleton yes
rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
Repco tab yes
repsidal
yes
rep Smith
rep Oregon
yes
rep dilorenzo yes
rep Schultz yes
rap wrong
yes
rep divine
rep Lanza
yes
rep Manos
repturer
yes
chairman Lynn yes
the motion passes 20-0
right and um
I'm sorry oh
all right
so um it's a 20-0 vote my uh although it
has an FN since it's an itl motion I
think it can go on the consent calendar
does anybody have any uh objection to it
going on consent
right so we'll put that on consent
um
next uh and this this we take up HB 290
and I guess
before we have before I recognize
representative Wallace for a motion on
that I want to bring something to the
attack this was this was one of the
bills that um
there I want to spoke to representative
Smith there was uh it appeared that
there would be a disagreement between
um
the majority and the minority
um the the majority was inclined to
recommend this ought to pass
and I apologize for this for not
catching this earlier but here is what
I'm I'm very concerned about as if you
look at this bill which seemed like a
very simple bill it proposed to allow
constables to make service of process of
Ritz
and that were in excess of 75 dollars
and I think all of all of us at least on
my side of the aisle sort of thought
what's the big deal if we change this
there didn't seem to be any particular
opposition to this bill as opposed to
187 which we'll get to in a moment
um the the thing that caught my eye
about four o'clock this morning was the
language in the bill that says
the the
um the Constable shell
and so then the question became what is
a constable so after doing after uh
calling Richard head at the judicial
branch and doing some research myself I
came across RSA 105.3 and I'm quoting it
to you now it says all police officers
are by virtue of their appointment
constables and conservators of the Peace
um what that means it seems to me is
that police officers are constables and
if we were to pass this bill we would be
saying that
police officers could be ordered
presumably at the request of a party to
serve Ritz that would be above seventy
five dollars so presumably a lawyer
instead of going to the sheriff could go
to a police officer with a writ for
three and a three million dollar civil
suit and say you have to serve this rip
I think if we were to pass this we would
be effectively nullifying what I think
will would likely be a motion to itl 187
which is the next one so my suggestion
is
that um we should
we should join with our colleagues on
the uh I'm speaking to the Republicans
here joined with our colleagues on the
other side of the aisle in moving this
be itl but I'm happy if people have a
different view on it I'm happy I don't
want to you know that's that's my view
if people have a different view we
should discuss it
all right so then I would entertain
I would entertain a motion to itl 290.
you have a motion on that or no
so moved right uh we have a second
uh second all right any further
discussion on uh House Bill 290
and as I say I apologize to my
colleagues I should have caught this
earlier and I didn't and uh but I'm glad
I at least I'm glad I caught it at least
before we voted so the
it looks like there's no further
discussion so then on the motion for itl
on House Bill 290 I think we're ready
for a vote
rep Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton
YES Prep trip yes rep Grayson yes
myself reputab clerk yes
repsidel yes rep Smith
reporgan yes
rep D Lorenzo
rep Schultz yes rep rung yes
Rhett Macbeth yes rep divine
yes
rep Lanza
rep Manos
yes rapture
yes
chairman Lin yes
the motion of itl passes 20-0
and again is there any reason that this
cannot go on the consent calendar
anybody have an objection to that
all right so
um it was seconded by representative
Tripp
um
and so it will be we'll place that on
the uh consent calendar
all right next
um we moved to uh HB 187 FN
foreign
I put them together because it's a
similar it's a similar bill
s for bills that we're expecting today
oh it didn't work I mean I'm sorry it's
I see where it is okay okay all right
so
HP 187 I I put those next to each other
because they deal with really the same
subject matter effectively so
um HB 187 permitting a police uh Chief
or other designated law enforcement
officer to serve process I recognize
recognize representative Stapleton for a
motion
I move that this bill be itl why is
there a second I second the motion
seconded by representative Andrus um sir
uh discussion on the bill
any discussion are we ready for a
representative Stapleton yes yeah I
believe this uh bill is is properly Ito
um we're short of police state police
and even Sheriff's Department
um and saddling local police officers
with process serving as
counterproductive to mission and goals
and safety and Public Safety it should
remain as it is now uh with the sheriff
and other appointed officers for that
right any other discussion on HB 187 FN
seeing none
um I think we're ready for a uh roll
call on that
Master clerk to call the roll
on the itl motion rep Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep Grayson yes myself
rep to tab yes
repsidel yes
rep Smith yes reporigan yeah yes rep
Delorenzo yes rep Schultz yes rep rung
yes rep Macbeth yes rep divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes repturer
yes
chairman Lin uh yes
the motion passes 20-0 right and again
is there any reason that this cannot be
placed on the consent calendar anybody
have a problem with that all right it'll
be placed on consent uh next I will turn
to HB 162
um and I'm going to recognize myself uh
for uh emotion of uh ought to pass and
let me get there but I'm gonna propose
an amendment
um hang on one second
uh I second that Mr chair
to all right hang on let me just find
the
Amendment
um
we're gonna vote on the on the uh
Amendment first so
um I have Amendment uh 116h everybody
should have a copy of that
it's a very
um minor Amendment this um
essentially takes out of existing law
the subsection B
in 464
D colon seven Roman numeral
um
uh
three
um
uh to read as follows it basically
right now in existing law there's a
sections a b c
um
D and E
this proposes to a to
remove what is referred to as subsection
B and is in uh brackets omitted and just
renumber the other ones
I move that Amendment and
um yeah I think you're oh that's right
may I ask a question Mr Turk
yes sir just a point of clarification so
what the paragraph that reads the
agreement is dated would become
sub-paragraph B little B
yes it would be that's right that would
become uh B that's right yes
any other questions
yes representative Oregon
I I actually and of course this was not
exactly the most interesting thing I've
ever done is
um trace the legislative docket of the
bill and it appears what happened is
simply that there's a drafting error
during a
conference committee report because the
House and Senate passed different
versions up and then this was supposed
probably should it would have been
normally been caught in the enrolled
Bill process but for whatever reason
that particular
uh
this particular problem fell through the
cracks and the actually the conference
committee report you know
skip straight from B to D without that
uh little emitted thing in there or
anything so
we're just correcting minor technical
error that you know should have been
caught
earlier in the process but better late
than never so
any
um any other comments on
uh the amendment 116 to HB 162. so are
you ready for the question
I did
well sex all right are we ready for the
question so we can do this by Voice vote
all those in favor say aye aye any
opposed
all right so now we move to the main
motion of uh
ought to pass as with this amendment
um you know are we
is there any further discussion anybody
have any any questions want to debate or
talk about anything all right that I
think we're ready for the roll call on
uh HB 162 emotion
ought to pass as amended
um so I'd ask the clerk to call the roll
please
rep Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
Grayson yes
myself repcootab yes
rep Seidel yes
rep Smith yes reporgan yes
rep Delorenzo yeah
rep Schultz yes rep wrong yes rap
Macbeth yes rep divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes repturer
yes
chairman Lynn yes
d-o-t-p-i motion passes 20-0
any reason that this could not be put on
consent
sorry seeing none and that will be on
um
all right next I've turned to uh HB 164
relative to prohibiting towns from
criminalizing the right to peacefully
and orderly assemble and the share
recognizes representative Qutub for a
motion
foreign
to itl
is there a second me Mr chair ref
Alexander seconded by representative
Alexander uh representative do you want
to discuss the basis of your emotion
we had the research uh person look into
this and it was found that there was a
case uh that went
through the Supreme Court and they
determined that it was constitutional to
limit protesting as long as it was
um the scope of it was was clear and
that you were still allowing protesting
somewhere else and so it was well
defined that it couldn't you know be in
front of a residence then it was
considered that it was an
unconstitutional
yes uh representative Horrigan well
something happened a lot we were being
asked to legislate on the basis of a
single anecdote and um
I was not necessarily confident that
everything the proponents of this Bill
said was necessarily 100 percent
accurate I mean even
so so uh in any case
and even if everything you said was
correct
um I'm not sure if it's improperly
handled and we should and we would have
needed like a wider range of instances
before tampering with the law of my
opinions
yes representative Stapleton
was that uh court case uh scotus or was
that State Court scotus thank you scotus
any other uh comments so I guess what I
want to say I really want to give kudos
to representative kutab on this because
uh my my inclination and I talked to
representative Smith and I I don't want
to put words in their mouth but I think
at least she was sort of thinking this
is that
I had real question about whether the
law whether the First Amendment would
Pro would allow a
uh this kind of local ordinance and uh
fortunately representative cutoff went
and got the Supreme Court case that
specifically deals with this it's been
well I asked our researcher to you know
to make sure that it was still good law
so to speak and it is and uh this is a
there's a Supreme Court case that's
really very closely on points from 1988
saying that these kind of uh ordinances
or laws can be valid and the basic
rationale for them is if it's limited if
the ordinance is limited to prohibiting
picketing in front of a in front of
somebody's residence that's okay because
there's a privacy interest in the
residence in other words the law
generally is that if if if somebody's
speaking and saying something you don't
want to hear you can just walk away but
if it's in your house if they're
picketing outside your house
that house is supposed to be your
Sanctuary so where do you walk then if
it's in front of your house and that's
the rationale
um for the for the uh for for the for
this Supreme Court case uh the other
thing I should say here is I my remember
very distinctly that the sponsor of the
bill told us at the hearing that
um the uh trial court in the case that
he referenced uh from over in new Fields
had not reached the Constitutional issue
well in fact the trial court did reach
the Constitutional issue and if you've
had a chance to read that decision it
was a 20 20 plus page decision this was
not some you know motion denied uh uh it
was a very well thought out decision by
judge all
um yeah and I thought very well reasoned
so I uh you know for all those reasons I
think that uh itl in this bill uh makes
makes sense
yeah representative Oregon the other
thing was
another is aspect this situation was um
the the official in question there
he doesn't really we don't really have
very tight security around them but it
would be reasonable to have a security
firmer around them for a primitive round
of in certain situations and uh
and in fact the same official uh
canceled uh
the governor canceled his uh well moved
his um
moved his inaugural speech to a TV
studio precisely because he had uh
security concerns about holding it at
the State House
think that's relevant to the bill I
don't think it's in the bill no I tend
to think I tend to think you're right
okay sorry that's all right
representative tour you had a yeah just
just adding on I I also think that
outside of the provisions that
representative
um you know uncovered there is a
constitutional prohibition of you know
establishing ordinances that just in
general as the bills titled you know
criminalize the right to peacefully
assemble so I feel like both things are
true yes no no I agree with that I think
and I think that there apparently there
are some cases that say you know if the
if the yeah if the if if you're
picketing not just in some particular
house but you're pick you know you walk
along the block or whatever that might
that might be a different situation uh
yes representative Waltz and um thank
you for taking my question what was the
name of that case uh
uh
frisbee Schultz was it Schultz okay
frisbee it's a it's a 1988 U.S Supreme
Court case still good law and one
follow-up yes
um
now the individual involved or the
parties involved in that case were they
elected public officials or were they
private individuals what was the nature
of that case because I believe it has
bearing
I don't I honestly don't remember if
they were a public official or you don't
have the expectation of privacy that a
member of the general public does being
that we're elected it was it was a
doctor that had an abortion clinic
uh
yeah I'm although I'm not you know I
guess I've been targeted at a particular
individual I still it's a particular
individual's house I'm not sure that you
know even the even uh a public official
doesn't have some
ability to bet you know to have a
sanctuary I agree it's a different it
makes it can make a difference I
definitely agree to that but um
we've defeated uh
online bullying bills against
politicians uh historically in in this
house very recently uh you know this is
kind of a parallel course
okay representative Smith
I have a question for which I don't know
the answer and I guess it has two parts
one is
um it
the home
an issue here is the home of an elected
official where
um the elected official resides with
his family
who are not public officials and the
elected official does have an office
which is available to the public
to express
um opposition uh
or concern about his decisions and
um of course I don't even play a lawyer
on TV but I think those are also
relevant factors at least in the
circumstances if not the laws no very I
I would say very relevant I guess to me
what I would tend to say is that
um to the extent that the rationale for
this bill was there's an ordinance in
this town and you know arguably others
that that is sort of blatantly
unconstitutional we need to have a
statue to kind of correct that it seems
to me that that that that that is not
true I may there may be you know maybe
there would be some as representative
Turner pointed out maybe you know if
somebody were picketing and they were
picketing along the block as opposed to
that particular house that might raise a
question as to whether or not
um the ordinance could be applied but um
I I guess I would say that for us to
pass this statute
um would would really not make a lot of
sense given that it's that the ordinance
is at least not you know facially
unconstitutional that that would be my
view
all right any further any further
discussion by anyone
yes representative I also felt very
strongly that it was a town problem and
if the town people didn't like the
ordinance and they need to they could
pull it back it's a very excellent
excellent point that's a very that's a
very good point
other discussion
all right are we ready for the question
all right then on uh I I'd ask the clerk
to call the roll please on the motion to
itl house bill 164.
rep Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes reptesterman
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
Grayson yes
clerk yes
repsido yes rep Smith yes reporgan yes
rep Delorenzo yes rep Schultz yes rep
rung yes rhap Macbeth yes rep divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes Rapture
yes
chairman Lynn yes
the motion to itl passes 20-0
and is there any reason that this uh
could not also be put on the consent
calendar anybody have a problem with
that
all right it'll be put on consent
uh next I return to HB 169 uh relative
to termination of Guardianship and I
recognize representative uh kutov
foreign
to adopt the amendment in otpa with
Amendment right and what is the
amendment I know we have it here but I
don't have it right in front of me
the amendment is
2023-0134h and it was just removing the
change in section B and only changing
in section c from a preponderance of
evidence to clear and convincing
evidence
does everybody have
that Amendment
oh okay
email yeah I emailed it out to everybody
okay oh
so I'm set okay so did
um yes representative
you don't have the amendment
so um just in I mean it was sent ahead
of time to the committee right to
evaluate I think just in the future if
you're proposing Amendment just have
copies printed for the committee just in
case that's all yeah just I mean does
any
oh yeah would you mind that would be
great if you yeah
oh yeah here we go we have one yeah
all right
to the non-lawyers the difference
between the ponderance of the evidence
and here and convincing yes
um so preponderance of the evidence is
the standard that is typically used in a
civil case like let's say an automobile
accident or a breach of contract and
essentially it means
51 percent for lack of a for lack of a
better term the way it's usually
explained in court is you know the
scales of justice that to their two
scales typically what a judge will say
is that to it to sustain Whoever has the
burden of proof to sustain the burden of
proof the party with the burden has to
tip the scales ever so slightly in that
party's favor if they tip the other way
or more importantly if they're if they
remain in equal balance then the burden
has not been sustained if the burden is
preponderance of the evidence
clear and convincing evidence is a
significantly higher standard of proof
it's to use the analogy it's not it's
not proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
which is the the criminal case it has to
be really you know spewed in favor of
guilt but it's it's somewhere in between
preponderance of the evidence and
proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt which
means it's got to be it's got to be you
know very clear that uh that the uh that
the person with the burden of proof has
sustained the burden of proofs
thank you
all right do you want to speak to your
uh your Amendment uh award and or the
underlying motion
yeah so in the the reason that I made
the amendment was dcyf had come out and
and
um
stated that they basically needed the
change in section B not to happen but
they were neutral to the change in
section c and
I'm in support of passing it I I do feel
like the burden of proof shouldn't be
higher
for a stranger than it is for a
grandparent and I think that we need to
think about the best interest of the
child and the fact that this child may
be ping-ponging around the women who
spoke at our session
did contact me afterwards and let me
know that her granddaughter has since
been pulled
from the father again so that child was
in the custody with the grandmother for
I believe she said it was like six years
then went back to somebody that she
barely knew for three weeks and then was
pulled again and it's just
a lot I think for a child and I I really
feel like
in the best interest of the child to
make sure that the evidence is correct
that they're in the right place
other comments on yes representative
Divine there there was there was one um
I don't remember who made the statement
and this is the only thing that I could
I could pull out of this was on line
nine of the original
um
document that we got it had grandparent
or guardian and and I was hoping that
somebody
and then further in it was any sort of
abuse not just substance abuse to have
an amendment made for that and I don't
know what the I don't know if we should
do that or and I'm not sure what the
correct
way to go about it is and I think on
your Amendment
um on line six on the everything that
you have there on line six is fine but
grandparents should be also slash
guardian and then substance abuse should
be maybe substance abuse or any abuse
yeah and and so would you be okay I
guess instead of saying slash or any
Guardian family member because I think
it's different when somebody my thought
is that when you take a foster child in
as a stranger
you can kind of distance yourself a bit
and not get that emotional attachment
right but when it's your family member
when it's your grandchild when it's your
your niece or your nephew it is so hard
not to get attached and for them to get
attached to in the family like to you
know their cousins or whomever else may
be living in the home yeah I'd be fine
with that I I understand the god the
grandparent now better I just know that
these were questions that were raised
during when we had you know committee
hearings and I just wanted them to be
addressed again
um and and two the um somebody like I
said had said any sort of abuse not just
substance abuse because abuse could be a
number of things and if
I just think maybe there should be that
Amendment added
other yes
representative Smith oh all right
representative Beth thank you so
I appreciate the work on this
um bill and I I my concern is that if
the grandparents have a higher I mean if
the parents have a higher standard they
have to meet when their grandparents are
the guardian I mean it might prevent
them from entering into the guardian the
parents entering into the guardianship
in the first place because a lot of the
times I mean we need this good
communication between the parents and
their parents and the child and
um
I I do I don't I don't understand the
reasoning why if it's a grandparent
that's taking care of the child that
it'd be harder for the parents to get
the child back to exercise their
parental rights and um
you know so I I kind of I'm worried
about that
other yes representative Stapleton
I'd like to speak on that
um the bill is specifically tied that
level of evidence clear and convincing
is specifically tied to the parents
substance abuse or dependence
the phenomenon of grand families which
was the subject of a bill some few years
ago by Senator Hennessey out of Lebanon
recognizing that so many parents are
deficient in the upbringing of their
children because of substance or alcohol
abuse that the grandparents are the
first line of defense natural for them
to take care of their grandchild and
family and I really applaud this
this amendment
um relative to focusing on substance
abuse which we know is very very
difficult to overcome I know people who
are Grand family parents for children
who are sub substance abusers and it's
very difficult for them to get out of
that condition and stay out of it
there's relapse and I think this hits a
nail right on the head
yes I think representative Manos and
then I'll get to representative Turner
um this this bill is under termination
of Guardianship and I find it troubling
that we would have two different
standards for terminating guardianships
um
and I think we should
um have the same standard uh which I
think should be clear in convincing in
both
um both sections so I would oppose the
amendment in the sense that it sets two
standards two different evidentiary
standards it actually fixes it to set it
to be the same standard
Instagram
the paragraph B currently says we are in
convincing as it's written now and I
took the change out so that it's not
changing
it so both power
B and C will be yes
yeah I I I think the standard should be
a preponderance of the evidence in both
paragraphs
right so other other comments um
representative yeah I just want to say I
I I do agree with the the comments that
representative Devine mentioned that it
does seem sort of odd to have a
provision that just carves out
grandparents and just carves out
substance abuse when there's a whole
range of situations that would be
covered and I I do however think that
moving it to clear and convincing
um given the fact that this is you know
a minor that got placed into into
guardianship because of some sort of
abusive um or difficult situation that
you know the idea that it would be just
a minor tip of the scales between
whether it's right or wrong to return
that that child to the parent yet
especially when they're not in agreement
that the child should go back which
seems like a too low of a standard
yes representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm sitting here listening to some
very thoughtful responses to the
incredibly hard work that our clerk has
already put into this I wonder if I
could suggest that
um uh representative and perhaps two or
three other members of the committee
could form an an informal ad hoc uh
subcommittee to look at this and come
back to us on Wednesday
with
um an amendment that perhaps answers
some of the concerns or at least
clarifies what people are thinking about
it would that be something that the
chair would entertain absolutely I think
that's an excellent suggestion
um the the and I want the only one other
thing that that I would say on this and
I I want to note here that um I um
if this if this were going to be an
ought to pass as amended uh by
representative cutoff's amendment I I
told my caucus last night that I would
you know if everybody if everybody else
agreed with this I would go along with
it because I you know I didn't want to
be the sort of one one hold out but I do
want to say that I am concerned about in
I have no problem with having clear and
convincing evidence in
subsection B where it's the guardian who
has is we're the replacing the burden of
proof on I am concerned about having
clear and convincing in subsection C
placing that burden on the parents
because as representative Macbeth
pointed out
my concern there is that what that means
what we're basically saying there
is that even if the parent
could show the court that it's more
probable than not that I have you know
I've cleaned up my ACT I'm now a fit
parent for the child that's not enough
the court still
cannot the court still cannot return the
child to the parents and my concern on
that is really they're a constitutional
one there is a U.S Supreme Court case
called Troxel versus somebody I don't
remember I don't remember the name but
it and it's it's not a it's been around
for you know probably 20 years at least
basic that the the basic upshot of that
case is that parents
have have very special rights with
regard to their children and that if a
parent is a fit parent it takes
it takes something more than you know it
takes something more to deprive the
parent of the child and so I have a
concern I'm not please understand I'm
not saying that I'm you know this is
clearly unconstitutional I'm not saying
that at all I'm just saying that I think
there's at least a question about it and
so that reinforces representative
Smith's idea that this is something
maybe we we should have a subcommittee
look at and you can just you know you
can at least take a look at that case
and see what you know see what you think
as a result of that
if you agree I would like to suggest
um
that perhaps
Representatives Macbeth and Manos who do
work in this particular area might have
some special skills that could help in
um and if the clerk is willing to sit
down with the clerk and I don't know who
else you'd like to suggest and it seems
to me it could be done in time for
Wednesday so I I think yeah and if it
turns out you know if you get really
into it it can't be well then we'll you
know we can do it we can do another time
thank you the calendar appropriately to
right yeah yeah yeah exactly so is
anybody else uh representative do you
have some interest in also being on on
this subcommittee you're more than
welcome uh I'd I'd be willing to
participate sure all right all right
great so then why don't yes why don't we
say uh Macbeth Manos enter will be the
subcommittee and we'll report back to us
does that sound
like a prep stable oh I'm sorry rep
sableton you um you have a strong
interest in this so I I don't I don't
wanna
for and send you into extra work if you
don't want to be involved but if you do
you're more than I think you're more
than welcome
oh I'm kind of jammed up now with any
number of family health and other things
going on and that's fine I don't I can't
fit it in no no that's fine so all right
so is everybody comfortable with with
that that we will we will not proceed
with this uh bill now and we'll we'll
hear from uh we'll hear from that
subcommittee on Wednesday
um all right
um
all right so let me then turn to uh
cacr5
um
uh regarding uh relating to fundamental
rights providing that the constitution
protects the right to marry and I
represent I recognize representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I move um
cacr5 and expedient to legislate right
is there a second
no I see how
is there a second to that motion uh
representative Stapleton oh yeah
uh yeah it's all right yes sir all right
um
right uh representative Alexander do you
wish to speak to the motion yeah just
briefly um
this looks like a very simple
Constitutional Amendment but when you
start making things simple things get I
feel like more complicated and you know
I I feel like everybody should have a
fundamental right to to get married
um I think the Supreme Court has dealt
with this very well I don't think
there's really any assault on the right
to marriage by anybody
um but I do worry that when we when we
put a question when we put a question of
the voters like this it might pass and
there'll be some very unintended
consequences to that
um I mean I asked during the the hearing
what happens when you'd like to marry
two or three or four people is that your
fundamental right
um if you'd like to marry a minor is
that your fundamental right I think that
creates a lot more problems than it
solves when there really is no assault
on marriage or anybody's right to get
married the way they'd like to
um in this state and certainly not in
the country so
although I sympathize with the sponsors
um intention of putting this into the
Constitution I think that we already
have that right
um and I think it's restricted in a
responsible way so with that I just hope
the committee would vote with me thank
you
yes representative tour
uh yeah I I distributed an amendment
that if this
um motion does not pass I'm hope I'm
saying this right that we might
entertain
um and uh it goes directly I think to
what representative Alexander raised and
it emanated from his comments during the
the testimony
um a a
feel that the there are some real flaws
in the original proposed
um bill
um particularly as a human right it
would Grant it to everyone
um and there are no clarifications and
so
um it would literally probably Grant the
right to
polygamy it would Grant the right to
child marriage at any age it would Grant
the right to incest
um
and it seemed as though those three sort
of flaws could be healed with a simple
change to language so if you look at the
amendment
um basically I ins are working with with
OLS inserted uh more or less the same
phrase in three places and and it it
basically adds the language of any two
natural persons at least 18 years of age
and outside of one degree of
consanguinity I hope I'm saying that
right that's a new word for me
um
and so we now would read the right of
any two natural persons at least 18
years of age and outside of one degree
of consanguinity to marry shall be a
fundamental right that actually
clarifies those four different things
one to your point it says it has to be
two the the the number two so no more or
less
um it says natural persons which might
seem like an unnecessary thing but if
you've all seen the movie Her with
Scarlett Johansson
um we're moving into new errors where
people can have relationships with
non-natural people and and it also
excludes things like animals which I
know are also a concern
um 18 years or older I'll come back to
that in one second and then one degree
of kansanguinity
um is ols's way of saying second cousin
or further which is the current standard
for New Hampshire
um so just go into the 18 and uh
um 18 years and and an older language
um I just wanted to clarify that would
not put it in conflict with our current
um rules regarding
um marriage even though some marriages
are allowable out younger than that it
just says the right would not be
guaranteed at 18. and under the age of
18. so it would still leave the
legislature capable of uh regulating
marriages below the age of 18.
um you know and and I know that there's
some current discussion around that so I
just wanted to clarify that that uh and
correct me if I'm wrong but that's my
understanding is that that it would it
would not be in Conflict
um
uh or you know or any other group that
is not covered by by the right would
still be uh able to be
um
constrained by or or or granted any
other sort of legislative
um marriage uh changes
um
so I think it places the what what we'll
call the right since it's the
Constitutional Amendment as a human
right sort of within the bounds of
current uh marriage law I read all the
regulations about the current marriage
law and it basically this would be
within all of what we're currently we're
doing
um so with that I guess I'd say I hope
you'd accept the amendment so we can and
I'm not going to speak to the bill at
this point just to the amendment to
discuss the bill on those terms
so any uh representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for amending it to
address some concerns
um I worry putting something to the
voters that's already a right because I
worry about what the unintended
consequence of it will be after I mean
nowhere in the amendment does it say the
right of two consenting adults right
there's not even like you don't have to
consent to it you could just be like Oh
I'm gonna marry
um you know somebody that can't even
consent themselves maybe through a
disability or or other means so I I
guess I worry this is going to create
more problems than it solves because we
already there's no roadblocks for people
to get married in this state so
um
it creates more problems than solves
that's all
other yes representative I realize I'm a
sub here so that's all right jobs can
speak too great thank you Mr chair
um
I think it is certainly
many people are of the belief that
certain laws that are in effect
currently
could be struck down by the current
Supreme Court
and in the U.S Supreme Court
and
wouldn't it be an awful thing for people
in the granite state if marriage
equality was struck down in the courts
since that really strengthened the law
for the whole country
um isn't doing this bill with the
amendment
making sure there isn't a gap because of
likely Supreme Court U.S Supreme Court
decisions
there's not a gap in what families would
need
for their choices by way of marriage
wouldn't this
recognize the fact that there's a decent
enough chance why leave future Granite
Staters
in limbo when they're eager to marry
other
yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair
um
I think the founding fathers of the New
Hampshire Constitution
is telling with absence of marriage
listed in in the document
and I believe that there's a reason for
that when when you establish uh in the
constitution of of writing the document
now you're you're being maybe too
specific and now you're going to have to
Define all the ensuing variables and
possibilities and
nuances that's going to come forth and
think that may have been part of the
reason why the founding fathers decided
not to enter that into the
Constitutional document I also believe
that at the time
the Reliance upon religious Customs
Traditions ethos
beliefs marriage was considered more in
the province of that aspect of human
culture rather than
some controlling Factor by the
government
I I think we're stepping into dangerous
territory here going into the weeds and
it would only
incur more
uh and more of um
law and clarification and documentation
on at night I would be opposed to the
amendment
other comments
um representative Turner
yeah I just wanted to Circle back one
more time
um on the the concept of consent because
that was was a consideration but I think
that the difficulty with including a
word like consent is that that brings in
some other statutorily defined terms in
terms of what it means to be able to
give consent and and seem to
um further complicate the underlying
intent of what what this was which is to
guarantee people the right to enter into
marriage 18 years or older which is
typically an age where where you can
give consent I do understand your
concerns with with
you know people who can't but
um I don't feel it's in in conflict and
so I I you know I this was introduced by
representative Heinz
um from you know from a different party
and I was hoping that we could
um
come together around the concept and and
make a statement that this sort of
oldest institution which I do think is
under threat specifically stated in the
dava's decision by Clarence Thomas that
that uh the obergerfeld version of of
marriage specifically should be
Revisited he didn't mention
um he didn't mention the loving decision
that that pertains more directly to him
but they were all tied back to the 14th
Amendment
um privacy uh
interpretation so I do feel like it's
it's a very
present
um concept that that could change and it
would it would threaten rights that
thousands of people in the state have
have taken advantage of
so I I'm uh representative Smith you
would requested I wonder if we could
just take a five minute
yes absolutely
not available
[Laughter]
foreign
what's going on Nate
thank you
everything
it changes
foreign
thank you
we're back in session representative
Grissom all right thank you sir
um
I think there is a misunderstanding of
exactly what the Dobbs decision did and
what it could potentially do
C speaking thank you
if the chair Cuts me off I'll cut off
but in the meantime I I think there's I
think there's misunderstanding of what
the dob's decision did and what it could
potentially do based on the statements
that were made in the ruling
what the Dobbs decision did was put the
determination of how abortion rights
would be determined
down to the state level so each of the
50 states can have their own laws there
would not be one broad federal law
that's per the 14th Amendment of the
Constitution
I can't remember now I am not an
attorney constitutional lawyer however
the Constitution says that the powers
that are not delegated specifically to
the federal government belong at the
state so when we consider all those
other potential uh brush fires that
could emerge such as the oberich fell or
the loving or any other rulings that may
or may not be dealt with
all that would do the precedent would
then be each of the 50 states could make
their own laws
that's all it would do some states may
do one thing another state may do
another thing and then if there's a
conflict then that would be brought back
to the to the Supreme Court for for uh
adjudication
what we have presently
and we're considering cacr5 is we're
trying to
prevent something
that's not even going to happen we have
a law on the books
and that's
whatever whatever the Supreme Court does
they're going to tell us we can do
whatever we want so I don't find that
cacr5 amended or not is even necessary
right any other uh comments
so I guess what I guess you know the
only thing I would say is that um it it
does seem to me that there is
um
that there's just as representative
Alexander said there's just really no
reason for this I don't um that that
um there's somehow there's a threat to
the right to marry I just I I candidly
just don't see how it where it exists
and bear in mind that this is a this is
a state law this would be a state
Constitutional Amendment if the if first
and somehow lightning struck and the
federal con Supreme Court
overturned one of those decisions that
was referenced that wouldn't mean that
there that there was
um that you couldn't marry it would be
it would simply be turned back to the
states and the state law now I don't see
any
suggestion that state law is going to be
changed in a way that would in any way
interfere with the right to marry
whether it's on a sexual basis or a
racial basis or or uh or any other basis
so
um I I just don't think that the amount
that cacr5 is necessary
all right yes the question has been
called
um is there a second on that calling the
question
I'll second second
I'll second it all right so
um we're uh ready for a roll call vote
on cacr5 and I would ask the clerk to
call the roll please um Mr chair just a
point I'm sorry it's a motion to ITF
thank you sir yes motion to itl cacr-5
representative Wallace yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Andrews yes
representative testerman yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative Tripp yes representative
Grayson yes
clerk yes representative Seidel yes
representative Smith yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Schultz
yeah so she yeah she wasn't here so she
doesn't vote representative wrong yes
representative mcbeath Macbeth sorry
representative Devine yes
representative lonza yes representative
Manos yes representative tur yes
chairman Lynn yes
it passes 19 to zero all right and is
there any uh you know what could
Constitutional Amendment can't be put on
consent because it well if we if we've
itl so we could but yes we can put it on
consent all right
all right anybody object to this being
put on the consent calendar
all right
um next I'll turn to HB 240
um and uh recognize representative
Alexander for a motion uh thank you Mr
chair I move um HP 240 in expedient to
legislature is there a second
uh representative kutop
all right
representative Alexander if you wish to
speak to your motion yeah thank you Mr
chair a lot of what I'm going to say are
what I would have said
um I said on the last bill I think it's
it's still the same
um I support marital freedom and
and this is the marital Freedom Act but
I don't think there's any obstruction to
marital freedom in this state so
therefore I just don't think we need
this bill so I hope that you'll join me
in itl thank you anyone else wish to
speak on HP uh 240. all right are you
ready for the question
but I would ask the clerk to call the
roll please
yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman rep
Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep Grayson
yes
clerk yes rep Seidel yes rep Smith
reporgan no rep Delorenzo no rep Schultz
no rep wrong
no Brett Macbeth no rep divine no
replanza no rep Manos
no Rapture no chairman Lynn yes
the motion fails 10 to 10. is there
another motion
Mr chair yes I move to retain HB 240
right HP 240 there's been a motion to to
retain and it's been properly seconded
uh by representative Wallace is there
any discussion on that motion
representative manner just a question
what would be the purpose of retaining
it
representative Alexander
um it's clear that the committee is
divided on it so
um you know the other motion would be
ought to pass and I don't see that that
would that would
pass either this committee so I think
retaining it and working on it this
summer would be a good idea
any other comments on
emotion of ought to pass
are you I'm sorry I've retained so are
you ready for the question
all right I would ask the clerk to call
the roll on a uh motion to retain house
bill 240. rep Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes
clerk yes repsidel yes rep Smith
no
reporter again no rep Delorenzo no rep
Schultz no rep wrong no
Brett Macbeth no rep divine
replanza no rep Manos no Rapture no
chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 10 to 10.
sure another motion
out to pass
there's a second
I second it all right
anyone want wish to just the motion now
on the floor is ought to pass is there
uh which has been seconded is there uh
any further discussion on that motion
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to please
call the roll on motion of ought to pass
prep Wallace no
no rep Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman
rep Stapleton no reptrip no rep Grayson
no clerk no
repsidell no
rep Smith yes reporgan yes rep dilorenzo
yes
rep Schultz yes
rep wrong yes rep Macbeth yes rep Divine
yes rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes repturer
yes
motion feel oh sorry chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to 10.
so the bill will go to the floor with no
recommendation
um and uh
um
so I uh uh rapper Alexander I would ask
you to write the report for the itl
um and representative Smith
representative Macbeth can you write the
report for ought to pass
um
all right
uh
I'm just hang on one second
okay
all right
um
all right uh moving on then to
cacr6 uh relating to the retirement age
uh for judges
providing that mandatory retirement uh
age
the judicial retirement age shall be
increased from 70 to 75. uh the chair
recognized representative cutoff for a
motion
I motion not to pass all right is there
a second
is there
um discussion on the on the motion
um
I guess I would like to just briefly say
for the reasons I've stated before I
think that it does make sense to uh
increase the judicial retirement age to
75 for the reasons I said it at the
hearing and I won't sort of belabor it
but I'm happy to answer questions if
anyone has wants to discuss it further
or has has questions about
yeah
it was made right
and Staples in second
um
is there um so are we ready
are we ready for the question yeah all
right so I would ask the clerk to uh
call the roll please on c a CR uh six
for the ought to pass motion rep Wallace
rep Alexander no
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip yes rep
Grayson yes
clerk yes
rep Seidel yes rep Smith yes rep
Corrigan no
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Schultz yes
rap wrong yes
Brett Macbeth yes rep divine
yes
rep Lanza yes rep Manos yes Rapture yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 18 to 2.
I know that's nope it's it's so you have
to go on the regular counter because
it's a constitutional amendment I will
not be writing Minority Report or all
right
um representative you were um
okay all right
um
all right
um turning to uh House Bill uh
663.
um
uh chair recognizes representative
greeson for a motion
um
Mr chair I move that uh House Bill 63 be
found in expedient to legislate what is
your second to that I second the motion
all right yes representative Greece
would you wish to speak to us oh yes
thank you
um I I know firsthand
that municipalities use zoning laws to
shall we say make it extremely difficult
for religious institutions to utilize
their properties
that being said I don't think this bill
actually fixes that problem and May in
fact even with the amendment that
representative Mooney presented May in
fact uh
present a situation where it looks like
religious institutions would not even be
subject to zoning laws
their
is no explanation of what it means to
provide housing for the unhoused how
long are we talking about housing them
uh what type of housing is it there's a
difference between a a homeless shelter
and apartment complexes or quad plexes
or anything like such nature so because
of some vague language and believing I'm
sympathetic to the cause I think that
there needs to be some assurance that
municipalities are not using zoning laws
to to put unnecessary uh hindrances to
religious
organizations from using exercising
their rights but I just don't think this
bill is actually it unfortunately
anyone else uh yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
um
I share concerns about the bill but for
different reasons
um but I was going to suggest that we
retain it for study
um so that we could address some of the
issues that I think we might have as a
committee with us I'm concerned about
the language of substantially burden
religious exercise and that that
language invites litigation
I'm concerned about the entanglement of
church and local government
who decides who has the burden of
presenting evidence
what's the burden of proof that's not
defined in the bill and then finally
the list that's provided is not either
exhaustis exhaustive or all-inclusive of
zoning regulations
so rather than itl I would like to see
this retained for
um for study
other
representative Oregon
um well I'm also opposed to the itl I
think actually my preferred option
my preferred option is to uh Delete the
entire RSA that this bill amends and
that's something we can do if we
overturn the ITIL and to move on that's
one of our options I was uh this bill
passed just last year and I was opposed
to it then so I understand
the concerns behind it but I'm not sure
whether and it's a
club or Association that calls herself a
religious organization necessarily
deserves special privileges in the
zoning law compared to ones they call
themselves secular uh organizations I
think there's a
I sort of think there's a First
Amendment issue here and also the
original Bill 2 is also is an anecdote
to evolving particular religious
organization in Durham and I'm not sure
whether that anecdote was uh accurate I
guess that's in the past but I think
so my preferred option
retaining is preferable to uh
leaving it as is but leaving the law as
is but I think my preferred option would
be just to delete the entire RSA
although I know that's probably pretty
pretty heavy lift given that given where
the rest of the committee is but that's
uh
so I'm voting uh so I'll be voting
against the itl for that reason yes uh
I'm sorry yes representative Char yeah
thanks
um so I
also like the idea of retaining the bill
because I think the uh existing
statute as I read it does have some
flaws one of one of the zoning board
members Maguire I think that came and
spoke to us said listed that existing
law the exemption the exemptions that
are listed because it basically granted
and then says except for all of these
things which are most basic zoning
regulations don't apply and he said that
list was not comprehensive so I think
there's flaws with the current law but
the new law I like the fact that it
narrowed it and said you you can't pass
a restriction that is solely on the base
of basis of religious purpose whereas
the existing law
basically grants it based on the fact
that the building itself is currently
being used for religious purposes so
it's a very different concept than what
the what the the bill said the bill I
liked better but the existing law
um has uh holes in it and so does the
bill so that's why I would think routine
other anyone else uh representative
Smith
thank you Mr chairman
um
all of us know that
we are
not just in New Hampshire but across the
country experiencing
um a very serious problem in terms of
access to housing
and we can come up with Myriad reasons
uh
for that uh
but as to for Solutions I think we're
all now looking at representative
Alexander's committee to tell us what
the solutions are so it's all on his
strong shoulders
and when he comes up with that people
all across the nation are going to be
cheering
um the I I share with representative
hurricane concerns about the initial
bill that passed uh last time this is
now an attempt to try to correct some of
the problems
um
but there are so many more problems
that exist so the bill itself isn't the
answer
but I don't think leaving
the underlying legislation as it is is
the answer either
um there is nothing that
would make a time difference if we were
to act on this now or not
itl just closes the issue I would like
us to keep the issue open in this
committee because we have a
responsibility as do other committees
to address some of these issues and by
retaining the bill we create an
opportunity for us to do some thinking
some deep diving if that's the
appropriate expression and see if we can
actually come up with legislation
that addresses the problem and meanwhile
we won't be adding to the problem by
just ignoring it so I would hope that
you would consider the possibility of
not accepting the itl motion and uh then
giving some consideration to a motion to
retain
thank you Mr chair
um other yes uh thank you Mr chair
um as a co-sponsor of this bill and a
supporter of the amendment I also
support retaining it so that the
sponsors can have a discussion because I
think we're getting in
not only with current legislation but
we're talking about property rights and
the separation of church and state to
address one of the most severe problems
facing New Hampshire and throughout the
country so I think retaining it can
bring in some voices and dive deeper
into this issue thank you
anyone else yes representative De
Lorenzo thank you Mr Claire I am in
favor of retaining it uh mainly because
I went online to look at
um the opposition and support of the
bill for the from the public and one
person supported it and 370 people
opposed it so I think that I would love
to see a deeper dive into this issue
thank you
other other comments yes representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair
I personally don't have a problem with
RSA 674.
and the last sentence in the bill was
displayed the building of housing to
house the unhoused by a religious
organization
shall qualify as religious exercise
under this section
well it's a form of Charity
religions of all types and kinds
do charitable work for Humanity and and
other people not only of their own
denomination but generally others and if
they want to build housing they've got
permit
um
and compliance with code
and compliance with existing statutes
and areas of housing or
medical or whatever is going to be
involved with the building so I think we
have a body of law that adequately
covers how that charity can be
manifested under religious charity right
other comments but I would be okay with
retain because it gives think time and I
think this is a big enough
item that it requires think time if not
a lot of it
right well so I guess what what I would
say is this I I don't disagree with the
people that say we should that this
requires some further work but my
concern is it seems to me that it
requires enough for the work so to speak
that
um it's unlikely we're going to get this
done and sort of a retained situation I
to me the people who uh who have
questions about you know should it be
changed in one way or another and I I I
tend to agree with representative Smith
that there are some issues
um
with at least some parts of the of the
of the current law uh but it seems to me
that there's nothing that would prevent
this from you know from uh in the next
session next year somebody coming back
with a bill to uh to uh uh change the
the uh to change the law if there's if
there's uh
some reason to do so
um as I say that I guess maybe I ask is
that will the would there would that are
you concerned that if we if we did that
that there would be a uh we would be
prohibited from doing that in the next
in the next
right
anything anything to do with that we
would have to
have we substantively different to bring
it back
right okay okay and I but I mean it's it
sounds it sounds like what we're really
talking about are substantively
different things aren't they isn't that
really what people are are saying
just feel that I listened carefully to
what representative Stapleton said
because I think he made some very good
points in his statement and
um he was reading from this language
saying uh
you know that he thought it was
appropriate as a charitable operation of
a of a religious institution to address
the housing issue I
too agree with him which is why itl
on this bill
is there some concern to me because that
language then disappears
um and we are left with the existing
language which isn't as focused as this
and so
um
I I think
uh I mean not Dakota
former president but I feel everyone's
pain on this on this uh on this issue
and I I would like to take
a crack and see if the Judiciary
Committee which has limited Authority in
terms of housing issues after all we
don't have Planning and Zoning we're not
the municipal committee
um
uh I I would like to see if there's a
little piece of it that we might
contribute to help
the problem until we could come up until
representative Alexander sauce the whole
thing for us and to be fair
representative De Lorenzo will be
solving it as well
all right
representative Lorenzo is that
representative Lorenzo would be happy to
let representative Alexander take over
Mr chair if it's appropriate at this
time I would withdraw the motion to itl
and make a motion to retain
house bill 63. before you do that let me
just hear from representative Macbeth
and then I will get to you
so I greatly respect my ranking member
and I um I really I feel like itl is the
best
um
vote for this bill we have the housing
committee special and we I think we
should let that take its course
um I also think the issues regarding
um separation of church and state are
significant and
um that's something that's going to need
to a lot of work and as representative
Smith said housing really is not our
main peer review so I would like this
bill could come back whenever but I
first of all would like the housing
committee to do its work and then
um you know if somebody wants to bring
it back they can but I I really think
itl is the best right so representative
Gleason in light of what uh
representative Macbeth has said uh does
that what do you still wish to withdraw
your I know that the motion was made and
seconded
so it would also have to be agreed to by
the one who seconds it I think because
of the fact that this is such a huge
scope problem
I do believe itl is the appropriate
motion and the proper action to take it
this is this is way too big of a problem
for this committee to try to solve even
over the summer as best of our
intentions maybe if we have a commission
to study this and to try to come up with
something what makes it think that we're
going to come up with it over the summer
time I think itl is the appropriate
motion and if the one who who at seconds
it would still keep the second
um then then I think the motion should
stay itl and let's go with a vote for
that if it fails I'll make the motion to
retain all right so that you you
your thinking is exactly my thinking I I
tend to think I I tend to think that we
should
uh itl this for the reasons that's been
stated but but if that fails I will I
will also be voting with representative
griesen to retain it so are we ready for
the question on itl
any further discussion all right I asked
the clerk to call the roll please
on itl for House Bill 63 Vice chairman
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman
rep Stapleton YES Prep trip YES Prep
Grayson yes clerk yes
rep Seidel yes rep Smith
reporgan no
Reptil Lorenzo
no rep Schultz no
rap wrong no
Rhett Macbeth yes rep divine
rep Lanza no
rep Manos
no
repped her no
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 12 to 8.
rep McBeth and rep divine
I will be a Minority Report
each other
well we kind of
yeah again I mean if you I guess really
it's it's a question for you
representative Smith if you're fine with
that then I'm fine with it too okay well
why don't we say that we'll let you know
with this 24 hours sure that's fine okay
um
okay all right
all right
um
uh next we turn to our last bill for
today is House Bill 256 uh prohibiting
cities and towns from discriminating in
the use of public facilities
and I will recognize myself for a motion
on that and and present um
uh first an amendment which you all
should have its Amendment uh 2023-1208
um
which um
you'll see it it I think it clears up at
least in my mind it clears up what I
thought was
um
some troubling language in the original
bill I should say that I've discussed
this um with the uh with uh
representative McGuire who was the Prime
sponsor of the bill and he was fine with
this language
um it's designed basically to say
that um
well let me let me just read no
municipality shall discriminate against
any individual or group in the use of
Municipal facilities for a lawful
purpose so it's got to be a lawful
purpose if you're you know if you're
if if you're proposing to hold a meeting
to talk about Let's uh uh let's
overthrow the government
um or let's uh let's go burn uh down
some uh some houses in some neighborhood
that's not a lawful purpose but assuming
it's a lawful purpose there can be no
discrimination
on the basis of the subject matter to be
addressed or the Viewpoint to be
expressed by the individual or group it
goes on to say that a municipality May
however impose reasonable and
non-discriminatory time place and manner
restrictions on such use and assess
reasonable fee this was another point
that was not in the original Bill and
assessed reasonable fees for the use
provided that such restrictions and fees
are applied equally to all users of the
facilities
um it seems to me that that's that you
know that
that language the the time place and
manner allowance of those kind of
restrictions
um makes sense it's certainly the
Constitution would allow that and so I
think that this does this will help to
ensure that uh municipalities sort of
treat everyone equally and don't have a
situation where you know if you have if
you have this Viewpoint
um it's okay to have uh to use public
facilities but if you have that
Viewpoint it's not
um so I for those reasons I think it's
uh I I hope that you will support uh I
hope you will support this amendment
yes representative Macbeth so thank you
um so I have two questions one you said
used example not overthrowing the
government but I doesn't our
constitution
guarantee the right to have Revolution
and I mean and I I'm I'm asking you
because you're the expert and then also
so I'm concerned about lawful speech
because I mean
um the right to be anti-holocaust or I
mean all of that's lawful but that might
not that's you know
it was all right so that can't be
discriminated against and the town has
to allow the neo-nazis or
um whatever anybody well you know I I'm
not that's an excellent question I think
it on the on the right to Revolution
you know that that's that is in the in
our constitution it's not in the federal
kind it is in ours
um I
uh it's never been construed and I it's
uh it's uh at least as far as I can
recall and it's uh it's hard to
understand Howard how it ever would be
construed to allow you know a group to
say we're marching on
we're grabbing our guns and we're
marching on the state house this
afternoon uh I would think that the
government would have a the you know
that the constitution is not a suicide
pact I guess I would say so I would
think that that
um and if then and I guess what I would
the other thing I would say is if the if
that provision applies it applies in so
many you know it could be used to apply
in so many circumstances to so many laws
uh you know I'm
I don't know that motor vehicle laws
we're you know we we we're we we want to
be able to speed because we're we're
we're exercising our right of Revolution
and we have to get to the state house
right away to to uh to overthrow the
government
um but but you know I think there I
guess the other point that that to to
the extent you talk about you know that
you use the the Nazi example
um I guess what I would would remind
everybody is you know there is
remember Skokie Illinois uh in the late
1970s when the Nazi party wanted to
March uh in a uh through a neighborhood
heavily Jewish neighborhood and it went
to the Supreme Court and they said yes
so you know however
however distasteful and I in fact I
think that's really kind of I think in
some sense that's part of the problem is
that
we've begun to restrict
the First Amendment the the exercise of
people's rights on the grounds of you
know I the I mean I think some people
today my sense is that
most people when Skokie was decided and
I think it was 1977 said you know as
much as we as much as we hate what the
Nazis are standing for we agree that
they have the right to do this to March
through Skokie Illinois and I'm
concerned that we've begun to narrow our
our conception of what is
constitutionally allowed and I think
that's that really is a problem because
it becomes
you know
uh
speech
I don't in any sense uh condone what
happened on January 6 but for for the
idea that
um that the president couldn't you know
if that the president couldn't go
to let's say let's just let's suppose
that that he wanted to go and hold a uh
hold a rally a couple of weeks later in
in a in a municipality in New Hampshire
that the municipality could say well
look what you did on January 6th we
can't you can't come here to have a to
to speak
to peacefully speak about whatever that
that kind of concerns me
so I misspoke I shouldn't have said
Nazis because I understand that I'm not
talking about just not liking speech but
I'm talking about misinformation and
stuff that's not right like the
Holocaust deniers or other things like
that but I'm just clarifying I'm not
going to argue about it but so you're
saying that this bill
um you're discounting the right to
Revolution which which I mean we're
talking about Free Speech it's not Motor
Vehicles here we're um and
municipalities
um
you're saying any speech whether it's
misinformation right or wrong it has to
be not just distasteful but
municipalities would have to allow it
they could not regulate
um the content of it and we've been
regulating the First Amendment for
hundreds of years I mean you know you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater and
a lot of other things like that but but
I just want to be clear with you you're
supporting this and you're agreeing that
no content can be whether it's wrong or
right or distasteful well no no I'm not
saying that I'm saying reasonable time
place and manner restrictions it seems
to me that that
um the uh and lawful purpose it seems to
me that that if you're you know if you
are saying
um if you are if what you propose to do
is to the equivalent of of have of
yelling fire in a crowded theater
um or pornography or you know that kind
of thing the traditional things that
have been held not to constitute a
lawful uh lawful speech that can be
regulated
um but if it's just you know if it's if
it's if it's very distasteful and I
think that's
my sense is
one of the reasons that that sort of
animates these kind of these this this
legislation is that there has been that
view that we you know in other words is
the the Nazis that wanted to March
through Skokie would that today be
called hate speech they what they wanted
to do was hate speech and therefore it
could be regulated I again as much as I
would hate what they say I would tend to
say no that's not you know that's not
hate speech well if it is hate speech it
cannot be uh prohibited and I think that
that the concern I have is that there's
there's this narrowing of what is the
permissible range of speech and that
troubles me a lot representative Staples
I uh circled on your and circled on your
Amendment lawful purpose
and you linked lawful purpose and
followed by subject matter addressed
the subject matter
um even if offensive is a First
Amendment
now lawful purpose
goes to what's the purpose of the uh Act
of of the Gathering or activity is it to
threaten and intimidate
I mean go back to Skokie
um they were probably protecting the
First Amendment as distasteful as that
was but but I would bet that there was
some overabundance of legal uh police
activity to make sure that they
mitigated
threaten and intimidate nature of that
particular March
so I believe this Supreme Court
recognized that that was contributory to
holding down the threaten and intimidate
aspect of it and that's part of the
reason why they ruled us the way they
did
representative tur
yeah one of the things that stood out in
the testimony on this bill from uh
representative McGuire you know is
basically he framed it in uh that he
could have sued the town he thinks over
you know their decision directly that he
felt that it was inconvenient you know
and that that going to the legislature
was the better way to go I I also asked
him
if he thinks he would have prevailed if
he sued the town he thinks he would have
um and I think that may go to this
question of is this already basically
you know guaranteed based on everything
we've talked about that this really
isn't isn't a needed law it just sort of
you know based on a particular situation
that arose you know
that we don't know whether the courts
would have upheld or not the town's
decision
um it just sort of short-stopped it and
went right to sort of creating new law
and that worries me
representative Alexander I think you
I I did I just wanted to contribute a
little bit I think like we're talking
about time place and Manner and I think
we're confusing that with like content
so like we have a right to regulate time
place and manner under the Constitution
I think it's already granted right but
um we don't have a right to regulate
content right and I don't think that we
should be able to regulate the content
um just make it safe for everybody to
Pro to speak and say what they like even
though it may be wrong or disinformation
to somebody else like you know you get
10 flat earthers in the room like you
shouldn't restrict them from be able to
talk about the Earth being flat you know
yes representative greeson thank you Mr
chair is the expression or some similar
expression lawful purpose anywhere else
in rsas that would this be something
that attorneys and judges would
understand the meaning of the phrase
lawful purpose
I think so I think I mean I can't I
can't tell you you know recite off the
top of my head other you know other
places but I but I I believe that you
know that language or language like that
as is used in a variety of contexts in
the law uh representative Manos
thank you Mr chair I
um
in my recollection of Representative
McGuire's testimony he also said that
there was one facility that they were
authorized to use and there was another
facility the Gazebo where the the band
stand that they were prohibited from
using so
um I I question whether I also question
whether this is necessary because he was
not being or the Republican group that
he was associated with was not being
totally excluded or precluded from uh
speaking in a public place but it was
one specific location
the other thing that concerns me is this
does not exclude commercial speech and
so a question of whether this would um
mandate that a municipality for example
allowed people to use a room at the
library to sell their widgets
and I would be concerned about that also
okay thank you
other yes thank you Mr chair when I was
reading the amendment and I'm sorry as a
sub I wasn't here for the hearing but
um it says no municipality shall
discriminate the use of Municipal
facilities I see this as a local control
issue that municipalities are elected by
their friends their neighbors people in
that Community who know what's the best
interest of that community and I would
um
I think they they are the best judge not
people at the state level for the proper
and appropriate use of their facilities
okay all right other other comments I
guess what I would just say is is this I
think that the I mean I think with
regard to representative McGuire's uh
testimony I I do agree that he but I
that he said you know there might have
been another place where I could have
but I think the the concern was that
there was a that some people were
allowed to use the place that he wanted
to use but he was and I this is my word
not his but he was relegated to
somewhere else and sort of felt like
wait a minute why why do why can't some
people use this but not me that's that
and I think that's the that's the issue
and in terms of you know on the leaving
it to the local level well
I think that's
that's the that's part of the problem is
we want it to be equal
yes thank you Mr chair well one
situation that I've been aware of in my
town of Merrimack in the past is there's
been some groups that have been allowed
to use it there are now forbidden
because they trashed it or they didn't
pay their fee and I was wondering would
this still
um with this amendment allow those
groups to be that the municipality would
be forced having to allow them to use
the facilities even if they have past
practice of misusing them I would say no
I would say that would be a reason to
say wait a minute you know you although
you say you're using this for a lawful
purpose your track record your track
record is that you have you know you've
trashed the last the last three times
you were here or whatever you've trashed
the facility
um or you've trashed other facilities or
whatever and that that's uh that's a
reason for you not to be allowed to use
it representative Smith thank you Mr
chair
um I've always leery about uh
the legislature passing a bill
that has to do with solving one problem
in one town
um maybe that's small-minded of me and
I'm willing to consider an alternative
but I wonder if anyone is aware
of any problem
similar to what our distinguished
colleague has experienced
in other towns and when we asked him a
little bit about this with that
wonderful smile he has he said well I'm
a legislator so I figured I'd just get a
legislative solution instead of trying
to find another solution it's like when
you go to a surgeon you know the surgeon
solution is surgery and I wonder if
instead if in this one case that's been
brought to us he had gone back and said
you know let's revisit this or if he had
chosen to go to go to court or do
something else
if the problem might have been resolved
and if therefore we would be
um
creating state law where there was no
need to do that
yes representative kouta
so I am aware of some other towns that
have stopped for example the lgbtq
community from holding events because
they didn't want Pride festivals because
they questioned the appropriateness of
having drag queens in in the schools and
I want to state that this would be like
after school hours or in the summer I
know my town did allow the event to go
on but there have been several other
towns that have rejected this so I do
think there are other examples besides
just the example that the sponsor had
introduced because I have heard of the
pride festival thing being denied in
several towns
oh yes representative trip
thank you Mr chair
I agree with representative Smith
during the uh the hearing I basically
said the same thing that
she mentioned now I I think this is a
point solution to uh a problem in one
town that is going to be applied
Statewide now that often doesn't end
well since uh most sounds aren't like
the town that this person lives in and
you know it just creates more problems
so uh I'm I'm in favor of italing the
bill
uh representative uh manage did you have
did you have your hand up does anybody
else have anything else they want to say
all right so are we ready for
um this is on the amendment are we ready
for
um a vote on the amendment and I and my
sense is we should not do this by Voice
vote but by a show of hands
um and then uh depending on what that is
we'll go to the main the main uh motion
because we have people in the room who
have never experienced this would it be
appropriate for me to point out that it
is possible to vote for the amendment
and then against the underlying motion
so that you know you're it's not a
question of Ingrid diamond for a dollar
if you think that you don't really like
the bill but the amendment would be
better
than not so I just want to make sure
people know that sure no no that's and
that's a very good point I'm glad you
yes representative man it is it possible
to make a verbal amendment to your
Amendment no no
and so we gotta we I you know in many
ways many times both last two years and
and this year I thought that would be a
great idea but we really it has to be it
is possible we don't have to the way you
you very appropriately set up
so we don't need any other permission
and if in fact you want to delay the
vote and um and submit and prepare have
another amendment prepared by OLS for us
to vote on on Wednesday that would be
possible so could I just ask you then in
light of that
comment by representative Smith uh could
you tell US Representative Manos what
you're what you're thinking your your
motion would say I I don't know the
amendment was saying yes I don't know
the exact language but its intent at
least would be to exclude commercial
speech so that we don't have libraries
forced into
allowing people to sell widgets snake
oil or Amway right right
um
uh okay
sure uh yes representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair
I'm having a pause even on the basis of
the subject matter to be addressed
um there's some awful stuff happening
out there and probably will continue to
be so that's outrageous
um does this prohibit
the municipality from
putting the brakes on a distasteful
obscene
extremely offensive
disturbing
subject matter
displays and so forth in the public
event
that's it so I as I
this is my view of this as I said before
I think if it's obscene
or it's you know a uh a
call to imminent violence or something
like that I think clearly that would be
unlawful under I think under existing
law the when you say extremely
distasteful
that's you know that's the thing that
sort of troubles me because I think that
gets to the the Skokie example is it you
know I think probably all of us would
say that uh the Nazis marching through
Skokie was extremely distasteful I would
certainly say that um but I tend to say
you know that they have the right to do
that and my concern and I think really
this is
I think this is really representative
McGuire's concern that emanate then from
which this emanates is that
it there seems to be a sense in many I
think many officials at both the local
level and the state level and maybe even
at the national level that
you know we can
we can say that certain speeches just
off limits and you don't the the public
doesn't have to listen to it and
um even
you know even the Nazis in Skokie as
much as I find that really really
distasteful I think that
our first amendment is designed to
protect that kind of that kind of thing
and that's I think that's the basis of
the
of the bill yes representative Greece uh
thank you Mr chair and I think the
amendment that uh may be suggested by
representative Manos would be to insert
the word non-commercial between the
words lawful and purpose on line eight
I I mean yeah that may well be uh I
would count on OLS to provide me with
the line so you know what can I just uh
in the interest of sort of uh of
lack of a better term not wasting
everybody's time could I just could I
just kind of get a general sense of is
that is that something that would make a
difference
in the final vote of of you know of
people who have expressed concern about
the about the legislation because if it
wouldn't then it you know it's it's sort
of a waste of your it's a waste of your
time I've
that's a fair question
so do you want to are you asking to vote
no no I'm not no I'm just sort of I'm
just trying to try to get us yeah
that's the proposed amendment has
suggested by representative Manos
how would you vote by Sean Penns at this
point in time please
in other words if you right on the if
let's suppose that that representative
manner that we had before US
Representative Manos amendment that that
said as representative greeson uh
suggested that
um so that it the the language of the of
the amendment was no municipality shall
discriminate against any individual or
group in the use of Municipal Municipal
facilities for a lawful non-commercial
purpose
so let's suppose that it said that but
everything else in the amendment was the
same
um could we just sort of have a straw
vote on what the on whether people would
be in favor of the Bill of the amendment
with that language added
um so I can have if you would be in
favor of it could you raise your hand if
you would be opposed to it well so first
of all people would be in favor of it
with that language
let's go
all right so what are we earning three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve okay and the people that
would be opposed to it even if it
contained that link
no we're just talking about the
amendment I mean right the amendment
people that would be opposed to the
amendment even if it contained that
language
even if it contained non-commercial
one two okay all right
um
okay well since it wouldn't be an
exercise it wouldn't be an exercise in
futility no then your next question is
that you have to think about is
if that Amendment were to pass right
would you
vote for the underlying bill right right
now that's a good question so maybe we
should have a strong vote on that so
let's assume that that that we had the
non-commercial language added that
Amendment passed which it sounds like it
might and now we're back now we're now
we're considering
ought to pass the bill would would you
vote to
otpa the bill with the uh with the
Amendments with the Manus Amendment
uh Mr chair I would want to hear the
discussion after the amendment is
presented I would honestly want to hear
the discussion before I can reached a
conclusion on the underlying bill
okay all right
um so you know I'm still gonna I I guess
I would still just ask for a strawberry
I'm not going to bind anybody if you
change your mind but I guess what I'm
saying is you know if everybody would
say that they're gonna they're gonna
vote against it even with that then then
I you know is there really any point in
in having that Amendment so could I just
ask if you would vote
let's assume that the amendment was
proposed with the with the accepting we
removing uh commercial speech from the
language
um and that Amendment passed and now the
question was will you vote for the bill
as amended with the non-commercial
exception in there how many would vote
for the bill
we have one two three four all right it
appears that that bill will not uh that
appears that we would not have uh
sufficient votes so it I you know in the
interest of not having you
um which will Implement your emotion
um I mean amend your motion and
amend them
well you know what I guess uh
I guess I'm I I really I mean I
understand where this is going but I
guess I'm gonna I'm I'm gonna
stick with even though it may I may be
on the losing side I'm gonna I'm gonna
call for a vote on the amendment and
that yes representative staple
well
I'm gonna throw another one in here and
I hate to do this but oh that's okay
um I don't have a problem with the
non-commercial aspect of the ad Edition
but
I'm reading this over a lawful purpose
on the basis of and I'm thinking should
that be lawful purpose solely on the
basis of the subject matter to be
addressed there may be other
considerations of safety numbers
management resources
um
conditions of the venue
and putting the words solely in there
does give us a little bit of latitude so
that it's not the most prominent aspect
of consideration
all right
um anybody else have any comments
yes representative D Lorenzo thank you
Mr chair
um I didn't get a chance to weigh in but
I am not opposed to
um allowing public facilities
to be used commercially
and I feel that way because there are
some towns that might have a a town hall
or a town Auditorium that's
um available for functions social
functions like weddings or you know
birthday parties or whatever and it's a
chance for the town to make some money
some extra income so
I think we have to consider that well
that's a valid point
um
so
I and I appreciate your your comments
representative Stapleton um I have a
sense that even with that even with that
language that the there there that
the the amendment would not pass and so
rather than sort of you know
having people go to the trouble of of
for of proposing amendments and writing
amendments that that uh would would just
prolong things I guess I'm gonna
what's that
sure so if we added the if we added the
solely length if if we added the solely
language that representative Stapleton
has proposed and the non-commercial
language that representative Manos has
proposed and if that Amendment passed
and now we were voting on the underlying
bill as amended and I asked for a show
of hands how many people would vote all
right sorry so if it says the commercial
part in there doesn't mean that they
could still accept commercial if they
wanted to because like our town for
example does do weddings and stuff as uh
representative dilorenzo mentioned
I and I would say yes it would just say
they couldn't they couldn't say they
couldn't say
um that they don't have to but they
could yes that's what I that's what I
would say uh representative Smith
I think we are all getting tired I think
we are
uh not that I don't love being with you
all
um but do you think that the possibility
that we're having so much trouble with
this amendment
is because this is really
a local issue that should be settled
locally allowing for the differences
from one jurisdiction to another
where niggling at little piece here and
little piece there and I'm not sure we
have to I think we might just
say this
we we understand the problem we respect
the concern and we believe
um that it is a decision that should be
resolved locally not that we are a local
control State we know we are not a local
control state but nonetheless there are
differences from Community to community
and um
and I'm reminded of something that we
all tend to forget it's not our job
to take a bill that doesn't quite
measure up and try to find a way to have
it measure up it is our place to take a
good bill that does something that's
clearly within our purview and try to
you know correct
try to improve it
um and
um I am very fond of the sponsor the
sponsor and I co-sponsors on some bills
so this is not
anything about that it's just that I
think
he's in the wrong pew
other other comments
yeah representative Alexander uh thank
you Mr chair I don't see an amendment
that will get a majority of the
committee to vote ought to pass or ought
to pass as an immense as amended so I
would suggest
that we just ideal
right yeah so you know I guess what I I
guess what I would like to say I mean I
unders I believe me I sort of understand
where this is going I don't I don't mean
to suggest that I don't but I guess I do
uh I have great respect for
representative Smith but I do for the
reasons I've said before I do feel that
this is a significant problem uh not
only in one town but you know generally
so I would like to have a vote on the
amendment and I understand that I I may
come up on the short end of that but
that's okay then we'll and then we will
go to if the motion if the amendment
doesn't pass we will go to uh
um
you know another motion so yes Mr chair
me I ask for roll call on the amendment
since it appears that it's going to be
yes no that's fine I I have no problem
with that thank you all right so let's
um so I'm gonna call for a vote on
Amendment uh one two o h two House Bill
256 and I would ask the clerk to call
the roll please
okay can I clarify this is just to amend
the bill then we'll vote on then we'll
vote on the right yes
Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman rep Stapleton no rep trip no
prep Grayson yes
clerk yes repsidel yes
rep Smith yes
reporter again oh
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Schultz yes rep wrong no
Brett Macbeth yes rep divine
yes
replanza yes
rep Manos no
repturer
yes
you can call me
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 15 to 5.
so now we're on to the
um the underlying bill and the and the
motion uh is ought to pass as we just
amended it and so I would ask the clerk
to call the roll on the
otpa
Mr point of order did was that motion
made and seconded
OTP I'm sorry I make the motion to but
that's yes good point yes yes it was it
was already you already motioned OTP and
you moved the amendment okay so yes one
second all right
um so I'm going to ask you to call the
role on the on OTP here
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews no
reptesterman
rep Stapleton yes reptrip no rep Grayson
no
clerk yes
rep Seidel yes
rep Smith no Rapport again no
rep dilorenzo no
rep Schultz no
rep wrong no
Brett Macbeth no
rep Divine no replanza no rep Manos no
Rapture no
motion fails
oh sorry by sorry chairman Lynn yes
motion fails 7 to 13.
13-7 sales all right so now do we have
another motion
yes representative Smith
is there a second
I'll second it I'm sorry uh
representative seconds
right
all right any is there any further
discussion uh if anybody has wants to
say anything they haven't said before
please do
all right are you ready for the uh
representative Square trip did you have
something you want to say
this is a this is a bad Bill I yeah uh I
think
what what's your
is is I've said this is a local problem
if if we make this a Statewide issue
somebody's gonna
take it to court and they're going to
Define what is allowed and what's not
allowed and that's a that's a problem
because what may be suitable in say
Nashua may not be suitable in Concord
you know and I don't think I don't think
that the the townspeople are going to be
interested in In Living the Life of
other people just because they got to
the courts first so that's why I'm
opposed to the bill
other comments
all right seeing Oh yes representative
Stapleton
well if this had happened to me
um
even if I'm a legislator my first
reaction would have been to go to local
Authority
or a plea to wave or to make an argument
failing that take it to an attorney and
bring it to court
existing law and procedure that we have
already on the books would be my first
Avenue
instead of coming in here and trying to
make a law no I I understand your point
that's I think that was representative's
point also but I understand that
um
all right so are we ready for uh the
vote on the itl motion
all right seeing okay so uh I'd ask the
clerk to call the roll on Ito
Vice chairman Wallace no
rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep Grayson yes
clerk no repsidell no
rep Smith
yes
prep core again yes
rep Delorenzo yes
rep Schultz yes rep wrong yes wrap
Macbeth yes rep Divine yes rep Lanza yes
rep Manos yes Reptar yes
chairman Lynn no
motion passes 16 to 4.
ATL all right
um
not on the consent
um all right so um okay
is there going to be a Minority Report
I'll let you know by tomorrow
so we got a TBD Smith we got a TBD Lynn
good for the ranking members good for
the chair right here
excellent all right I think we are done
um Mr chair before yes you send us off
for tea and trumpets
um could you just review
the issues that are still open from
today
um one of them is that you have to
decide whether you're going to do
I'm a Minority Report on on the last uh
HB 256 right yeah and
and they were doing
63. I'm 63 right and
um the clerk
has but she doesn't have enough to do a
subcommittee before Wednesday right on
on uh
on one 169 right and then for House Bill
240 Rhett Macbeth is writing a Minority
Report I just wanted to note that just
because that's the only one
yeah who is writing
words
okay
um
all right
um so there so on 240 you'll let us know
you'll you'll let miss your
representative Smith know within 24
hours if you're going to write a
Minority Report on on 240 all right um
I think we do too
I'm most of us don't eat sauce
thank you
for hours all right
all right thank you I'm gonna leave some
Dove chocolate out and welcome anyone to
have it oh great all right so is there
anything else um to thank the
substitutes oh yes
for sure
um
so is there anything else that we need
to discuss
seeing none uh I think we're adjourned
and we'll see everybody on Wednesday at
9 00 A.M great thank you